I was 14 years old inside of a bowling
alley burglarizing an arcade game and
upon exiting the building a security
guard grabbed my arm so I ran I ran down
the street and I jumped on top of a
fence and when I got to the top the
weight of 3,000 quarters in my bookbag
pulled me back down to the ground so
when I came to the security guard I was
standing over top and he said next time
you little punk steal something you can
carry yeah I was taking a juvenile hall
and when I was released into the custody
of my mother the first words my uncle
said was how did you get caught I said
man the book bag was too heavy he said
maybe one supposed to take all the
quarters I said man it was small what am
I supposed to do and ten minutes later
he took me to burglarize another arcade
game we needed gas money to get home
that was my life I grew up in Oakland
California with my mother and members of
my immediate family addicted to crack
cocaine my environment consisted of
living with family friends and homeless
shelters often time dinner was served in
bread lines and soup kitchens big homie
told me this money rused the world and
everything in it and in these streets
money is king and if you follow the
money it'll lead you to the bad guy or
the good guy
soon after I come into my first crime
and it was the first time that I was
told that I had potential and felt like
somebody believed in me nobody ever told
me that I could be a lawyer doctor or
engineer I mean how was I supposed to do
that I couldn't read write or spell i
was illiterate so I always thought
crying was my way to go and then one day
I was talking to somebody and he was
telling me about this robbery that we
can do and we did it the reality was was
that I was growing up in the strongest
financial nation in the world the United
States of America while I watched my
mother stand in line at a blood bank
to sell her blood for $40 just to try to
feed her kids she still had the needle
marks on her arms to this day to show
for that so I never cared about my
community they didn't care about my life
everybody there was doing what they was
doing to take what they wanted the drug
dealers the robbers the blood bank
everybody was taking blood money so I
got mugged by any means necessary I got
mines financial literacy really didn't
rule the world and I was a child slave
to it
following the bad guy at 17 years old I
was arrested for robbery murder and I
soon learned that finances in prison
rule more than they did on the streets
so I wanted in one day I rushed to grab
the sports page of the newspaper so my
selling can read it to me and I
accidentally picked up the business
section and it's old man said hey
youngster you pick stocks and I said
what's that he said that's the place
where white folks keep all the money and
it was the first time that I had saw a
glimpse of hope a future he came in his
brief description of what stocks were
but it was just a glimpse I mean how was
I supposed to do it
I couldn't rewrite her spell the skills
that I had developed to hide my
illiteracy no longer worked in this
environment I was trapped in the cage
pray among creditors fighting for
freedom I never had I was lost
tired and I was out of options so I 20
years old I did the hardest thing I've
ever done in my life I picked up a book
and it was the most agonizing time of my
life trying to learn how to read the
ostracizing for my family the homies
it was rough man it was a struggle but
little did I know I were receiving the
greatest gifts I'd ever dreamed of
self-worth knowledge discipline I was so
excited to be reading that I read
everything I can get my hands on candy
wrappers clothing logo street signs
everything
I was just reading stuff he's reading
stuff I was so excited to know how to
read know how to spell the homie came up
said man what you eatin I said see a nd
you eye candy he said let me get some I
say in oh no it was awesome I mean I can
actually now for the first time in my
life
read the feeling that I got from it was
amazing and then that 22 feeling myself
feeling confident I remember what the og
told me so I picked up the business
section of the newspaper I wanted to
find these rich white folks so I look
for that glimpse as I further my career
and teaching others how to financially
manage money and invest I soon learned
that I had to take responsibility for my
own actions true I grew up in a very
complex environment but I chose to
commit crimes and I had to own up to
that I had to take responsibility for
that and I did I was building a
curriculum that could teach incarcerated
men how to manage money through prison
employments properly managing our
lifestyle will provide transferable
tools that we can use to manage money
when we enter society like the majority
of people did who didn't commit crimes
then I discovered that according to
market watch over 60% of the American
population has under $1,000 in savings
Sports Illustrated said that over 60% of
NBA players and interfere players go
broke 40% of marital problems derived
from financial issues what the hell
you mean to tell me that people work
their whole lives buying cars clothes
homes and material stuff where would
living check the check
hi in the world remember some society
going to help incarcerated individuals
back into society if they couldn't
manage their own stuff we screwed I
needed a better plan this is not gonna
work out too well so I thought I now had
an obligation to meet those on the path
and help I mean it was crazy because I
now cared about my community I imagined
that I cared about my community
financial illiteracy is a disease that
has crippled minorities in the lower
class in our society for generations and
generations and we should be furious
about that actual selves this how can
50% of the American population be
financially illiterate
in the nation driven by financial
prosperity our access to justice our
social status living conditions
transportation and food are all
dependent on money that most people
can't manage it's crazy
it's an epidemic and a bigger danger the
public safety than any other issue
according to this California Department
of Corrections over 70% of those
incarcerated have committed or have been
charged with money related crimes
robberies burglaries fraud larsson
extortion and the list goes on
check this out a typical incarcerated
person we enter the California prison
system with no financial education earn
30 cents an hour over $800 a year with
no real expenses and save no money upon
his parole he will be giving $200 gate
money in tow hey good luck stay out of
trouble don't come back to prison with
no meaningful preparation or long-term
financial plan what does he do at 60
get a good job or go back to the very
criminal behavior that led him to prison
in the first place
you taxpayers you choose well
his education already chose for him
probably so how do we cure this disease
i co-founded a program that we call
financial empowerment emotional literacy
we call it field and it teaches how do
you separate your emotional decisions
from your financial decisions and the
four timeless rules to personal finance
the proper way to save control your cost
of living borrow money effectively and
diversify your finances by allowing your
money to work for you instead of you
working for it incarcerated people need
these life skills before we re-enter
society you can't have full
rehabilitation without these life skills
this idea that only professionals can
invest and manage money is absolutely
ridiculous
and whoever told you that is lying a
professional is a person who knows his
craft better than most and nobody knows
how much money you need have or want
better than you which means you are the
professional financial literacy is not a
skill ladies and gentlemen it's a
lifestyle financial stability is a
byproduct of a proper lifestyle a
financially sound incarcerated person
can become a taxpayer citizen and a
financially sound taxpayer citizen can
remain one this allows us to create a
bridge between those people who we
influence family friends and those young
people who still believe that crime and
money are related so let's lose the fear
and anxiety for the big financial words
and all that other nonsense that you
burn out to a hearing and let's get to
the heart of what's been crippling our
society from taking care of your
responsibility to be better life
managers and let's provide a simple and
easy-to-use curriculum that gets to the
heart
the heart of a financial empowerment in
emotional literacy really is now if you
said now you in the audience you said oh
yeah what I need me and I'll buy it they
come take my class so I can show you how
much money you cost you every time you
get emotional
[Applause]